monsieur le premier ministre vous allez
recevoir aujourd'hui et demain le
président de la république islamique
d'iran et vous permettrait tout d'abord
de vous féliciter pour n'avoir pas jugé
nécessaire de voile et les statuts
dénudé de paris notamment celle de la
place de la concorde à l'instar de ce
que les autorités italiennes ont jugé
bon de faire hier à rome en mettant sous
sarcophage les statuts du capitole reste
que cette visite appel plusieurs
questions que vous c'était vous posez
première question l'accord nucléaire
signé le 14 juillet dernier gel le
programme nucléaire sans le supprimer
pendant une quinzaine d'années
quels sont selon vous dès lors que les
sanctions sont levés nos perspectives
dans ce pays et surtout quelle est notre
capacité de remettre éventuellement ces
sanctions si ça devenait nécessaire
deuxième question quelle est votre
évaluation des marges de manoeuvre du
président roi ni dans un pays qui est
encore largement tenues par la
hiérarchie religieuse et qui persiste à
vouloir rayer israël de la carte
troisième question la france a donné
l'impression sous françois hollande de
se rapprocher très étroitement certains
diront de s'aligner sur l'arabie
saoudite alors même que se déroule une
véritable guerre par procuration entre
l'arabie saoudite sunnite et l'iran
chiite
aussi bien au liban en irak au yémen
et bien sûr en syrie il ne peut pas y
avoir de règlement dans cette guerre de
syrie qui ment dans sa sixième année
sans qu'il y ait de dialogue avec les
syriens et avec les russes que
l'opposition n'a cessé de vous dire
depuis trois ans mais ils sont aussi
qu'il y ait de dialogue entre l'arabie
et l'iran qu'elles sont monsieur le
premier ministre les marges de manoeuvre
de la france pour servir de négociateurs
de facilitateur à un dialogue entre
l'arabie saoudite et l'iran alors même
que nous recevons de plus en plus et le
terrorisme et les vagues migratoires en
provenance de syrie la parole et à
matthias fekl secrétaire d'état chargée
du commerce extérieur de la promotion du
tourisme et des français de l'étranger
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
pierre lellouche vous interroger le
gouvernement sur l'iran et il ya
beaucoup de questions dans votre
question je vais essayer de répondre à
chacune d'elles d'abord sur les
sanctions
vous avez raison de dire que la levée
des sanctions est maintenant en vigueur
suite à l'accord de vienne du 14 juillet
dernier et vous connaissez le rôle joué
par la diplomatie française à travers
laurent fabius à cet égard avec une
position de fermeté constructive l'
agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique a constaté à la mi-janvier que
toutes les conditions étaient désormais
réunies pour la levée des sanctions et
nous en sommes donc à ce qui est appelé
dans cet accord le jour de mise en
oeuvre les sanctions sont onusienne
européenne et il existe aussi des
sanctions unilatérales américaines
cet accord ouvre une nouvelle phase dans
nos relations avec l'iran et il y a des
perspectives de coopération économique
culturel et diplomatique très large
la visite du président hu a ni ici en
france d'ailleurs préparé de manière
très approfondie par le déplacement de
jean pierre raffarin et du président
larcher va permettre d'évoquer
l'ensemble de ces sujets dans le cadre
du respect de l'accord de vienne est
lorsque nous étions avec stéphane le
foll en iran à la fin de l'année
dernière nous avons pu évoquer
l'ensemble des sujets c'était le premier
déplacement d'eau ministre en charge du
secteur économique depuis 12 ans vous
avec nos échanges ont été divisés par 9
450 millions d'euros en 2004 454
milliards pardon d'euros en 2004 contre
450 milliards d'euros en 2014
nous souhaitons maintenant aller de
l'avant y compris pour avancer sur la
paix la stabilité et la sécurité dans la
région
le dialogue avec l'arabie saoudite et la
france grand pays membres permanents du
conseil de sécurité
échanges et dialogues avec tous les deux
pays sont des acteurs majeurs pour la
paix et la stabilité dans cette mer si
la parole est à mme adam